oh boy huh happy tuesday everyone huh
happy tuesday so let's get into it joe
biden's popularity is like his teeth at
night
underwater
if he sunk any deeper he'd have
crabs because he'd be in the sea
that's where the crabs live
it's your mind out of the gutter
his approval rating is at 39 percent
even after the row versus wade leake
which was designed to breathe life into
his unconscious presidency it was one
biden leak that didn't demand a change
of pants
but it still didn't work in fact thanks
to idiots heading to the justices houses
like they were invited to a barbecue it
quickly turned into a freak show
but with more bearded ladies
underrated by the way when you saw the
protests you probably like me wish their
mommies had been as pro-abortion as
their offspring
[Applause]
why not that's how you support him
you also were reminded that pro-choice
doesn't always mean choosing soap and
water
the worst stat of all this jaw-dropping
one from nbc news 75 of the population
thinks this country is going in the
wrong direction
that's astounding you couldn't get more
agreement from a room of children if you
yelled who wants ice cream and no
homework
meanwhile 16 think the country is headed
in the right direction which raises the
question who the hell is this 16 percent
[Music]
[Laughter]
just as i suspected a cnn production
meeting
so we live in polarizing times we're
told and the polarization is driven by
the media that does all it can to keep
us at each other's throats
they see everything through the lens of
identity politics and everywhere they
look except in the mirror is proof of
racism i thought that would destroy
america but instead it's destroying the
democratic party in places like cnn and
msnbc they're losing viewers and it's
created unity a near unanimous belief
that the country's going in the wrong
direction
so congrats to sleepy joe for bringing
the country together
on something other than a desire to take
away his car keys
so when you have nearly 80 saying we're
going off a cliff that's not
polarization that's a realization that
we're heading no place good seriously
when your car is barreling toward the
grand canyon you don't argue about
changing the radio station well unless
it's playing maroon 5
then you might speed up
see the party in charge suffers from a
weird flaw it's a lack of imagination
they can't see ahead of themselves the
problems we experience are obvious high
crime high inflation high illegal
immigration and yet these problems don't
exist until they become political ones
they simply do not exist until they
create a risk for losing power but then
it's too late so they scream racism
what does this do to the party in power
well it makes them ill-equipped to
prevent or solve an actual problem those
muscles have atrophied from disuse
and take crime apparently it doesn't
exist until it affects polling or their
own personal safety not yours then the
democratic party acts like my stomach
when i have dairy
you know once you do it you no longer
have time to deal with it
it's disgusting their goal is to win
elections not to stop crime shouting to
fund the police can win big city voters
but when what do you tell the same
voters after the election when their
neighborhood's burning like that rash i
got from sharing jesse's gym towel
as long as the election's far away then
crime can continue anything bad can
continue the dems being in the majority
joe's presidency the seth meyers show
he's on late night if you don't know who
he is
and then suddenly as the midterms loom
they panic crime matters so does gas
prices so it's getting food on the table
then they mimic republicans hey we're
anti-crime too we need more cops they're
like the mobbed up guy who breaks all
the windows in your neighborhood and
then just happens to be the owner of the
new glass shop that opens around the
corner
you get this because you're not a
politician you have a real job when
faced with a problem that needs fixing
you fix it right away because you have a
boss you have deadlines job reviews and
pride
you don't have the luxury of a political
machine that makes sure you can keep
your job every two or every four years
for democrats they only work when they
are campaigning and winning an election
is a reminder that it's time to relax
and do nothing
just when you roll up your sleeves they
roll theirs back down what's joe got to
say
no no no no look look uh 39
those numbers aren't so bad i mean the
uh
you know that guy brandon you got to
remember uh brandon's probably got a 35
approval and uh
the thing you got to remember i'm
brandon all right all that stuff let's
go brandon let's go brain you got to
give that number to me so 39 and uh you
know brandon and so we're up at about 74
and
and then 10 for the big guy and we're
over 80.
come on man yes
i suppose i suppose this is why trump
came across so unusually he was always
in campaign mode or what we would call
work mode almost all the time he entered
the job
to work and what a novel concept that
was a politician elected by the people
working tirelessly for the people who
elected him
no wonder all the lazy bastards hated
him
let's welcome tonight's guest
she talks faster than the guy listing
the side effects on a drug commercial
outnumbered co-host emily compagno
even if you hate musicals he'll make you
a fan of oklahoma oklahoma gop candidate
for u.s senate t.w shannon
she aims to deceive which is why a yak
grew her weave
fox news contributor cat tim
and
when he donates blood the red cross
takes a two-week vacation my massive
sidekick in the nwa world television
champion iris
emily long time no see
it's been a long five minutes it really
has we just did the uh live together
yeah it was really really great
yeah
i'm totally lying
do you feel the country's going in the
wrong direction and is it salvageable
you have 10 minutes
i always hold out hope you know i'm an
optimistic person so i think it's
absolutely salvageable but yes i think
it's headed in the wrong direction and
keep in mind that the rest of the 78
plus percent of the country who feel the
same way i do represent the lowest marks
in biden's his and biden's tenure thus
far right but the number that stands out
to me is that 65 percent of americans
think that their level of income is
falling behind the cost of living and
the most important thing to them right
now is the cost of living living
followed by the economy and jobs it's
not spelling women with an ex like
michelle obama would have you know right
it's not putting crt in the school
curriculum like pelosi would have you
think so to me the the real americans
whose priorities are liberty and faith
and family and freedom and being able to
earn your living unencumbered by this
bloated government or the creep crypt
keeper that runs it then yes believe
it's salvageable absolutely but
hopefully because of the red wave in the
fall because what these numbers
represent to me is that the cluster the
last time it was this bad was in 2008
and that's when raiders had a 5 and 11
record and therefore there's only a way
to go up but uh
it makes sense in my head right yes you
know the raiders
are are they still around yes uh i don't
know being amazing you're in vegas now
gut fell yes that's that's where they
belong yes in vegas
you know why because whatever whatever
stays in vegas yeah whatever yeah
amazing yeah whatever yeah this is vegas
thank you very much
tw yes sir good to see you good to see
you um why is it that the democrats
don't care about an issue until it's a
political one it drives me crazy because
they would life would be so much easier
if they actually tried to solve things
yeah no there's no doubt the democrats
have one motive and one motive only and
they've been exposed for donald trump
did a great job exposing the democrats
and what we figured out is they have one
mission and that is they are going after
our children the democrats are after the
children of america whether it's crt or
whether it's this gender confusion
they're trying to create a country where
we forget who we are i mean we talk a
lot about making america great again but
you got to ask yourself what made this
country great to start with the things
that made this country great i call it
the three c's greg it's our it's our
constitution it's capitalism and
christianity for religious for religious
liberties that's the reason this country
is great that's why we have one million
people that immigrate to this country
legally and 2.5 million are trying to
get here illegally i mean just remember
a few months ago we saw people literally
grasping onto the wings of airplanes to
get to this country we saw mothers
handing their babies to a newborn a
newborn child to a soldier who had a m16
on his hip she didn't know that man she
didn't know anything about him the only
thing she knew was he had the old red
white and blue on his shoulder and that
was enough for her to know if her kid
could just get here it'd be pretty
spectacular but the democrats are trying
to rewrite our history that's why
they're trying to destroy our history
because they want to remake us into this
socialist
agenda about looking more like europe
and we're not that's not who america's
ever been that's who we're not going to
be as long as we have people that are
running from the right to do the right
thing i agree with you except for the
three c's minor captain crunch
[Laughter]
they're not
you're you're lying
i love captain crutches which kind well
just the original except it's strips if
you don't have the crunch berries in it
yeah
i did like a 40-minute podcast about
captain crush i'm on a mission to be the
new captain crunch and no i don't have
any experience but it's all right right
now oh i think you'd be a great captain
i think so too yes exactly you know um
you uh the lady over here emily was
talking about how they the
problem with the democratic party is
they're always focusing on other weird
like you know the ex and women and stuff
like that this is kind of your
wheelhouse this is something that you
always talk about wheelhouse's expertise
yeah
they live in they live in oh man you
glared at me
do not throw at your chair you're used
to the glares by now we've been glaring
at you for like what eight years
uh
and they don't want to deal with
anything and then even when they're
given
uh an opportunity
to give solutions this just not in their
as you said wheelhouse yes thank you
will not own they just point fingers you
don't elect someone to tell you whose
fault it is we don't it's like my mother
you say i don't care whose fault it is
who is going to clean up this living
room with the broken furniture in it
who's going to do that
i mean my brother would look at each
other and be like i guess us and that
was the solution right also admitting
that we actually did it yeah but
we have no solutions in this country so
emily's optimism i'm not i'm looking at
the next two years are going to be even
worse we're going to see more
ridiculousness more refusal to make
changes and trying to jump on things
like the leak and making that the
election issue they are hoping that more
people care about your right
to choice opposed to high crime
inflation
poor education
not having anything in the house
that's what they're hoping will win the
election so there's no attempt to try to
fix real problems they're going to stay
over there and i don't see them budging
interesting kat um it's kind of amazing
that we almost have 80 percent
of america agreeing on one thing that
almost never happens
right when was the last time 80 75 80
ever agreed on anything other than that
i'm awesome
and that you owe everything to me that's
up around 90
oh
and have you been listening to my inner
monologue
[Laughter]
just kidding i did it all myself
um look i the because it's pretty
obvious and i think the worst part is is
that the government is so big that we
have to care right i wouldn't bother me
so much if the country was going in the
wrong direction and i could just say see
you guys right you know like but that's
not how it is it affects me directly
because the government's so huge if i
could just walk around do my own thing
with my own money carrying my own gun i
wouldn't care yes but i can't do any of
those things so
but does that really bother people as
much as it should
i don't really know this is why you can
no longer it sucks because you can never
be a small government person anymore
it's like with that that that argument's
over so it's like if i like for example
if i want to move to the woods or
whatever get away from everything
government's still going to come and get
you because it's that bloated it's till
i start my new country catastan yes
everyone's free in catastrophe that is
true where are you gonna where is he
gonna be well i think i'll have to start
at my apartment
you're gonna build a wall yeah
it depends i mean like how much real
estate can i get for cadistan you know
so far i need to own one property i'm
working on it yes
well i root for you no matter what
happened something wrong with her
up next should companies that stock
shelves keep their politics to
themselves
all right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else